hello grammarians today we're going to
talk about two sets of frequently
confused words hear and hear and accept
versus accept these words are pronounced
very similarly to one another but they
have very different meanings
and so what i'm going to try and do is
define these words for you and then come
up with mnemonic devices memory aids to
help you keep them straight
so the word here h-e-a-r
is a verb
and it means to listen
to
sense something with your ears
the word h-e-r-e here
is an adverb
and it signals that something is close
by
so an example for the the verb here is
to say
i hear
i don't know bird song i hear bird song
oh so lovely
there's our beautiful bird there's it's
beautiful song and we're hearing it
now in order to remember that h-e-a-r
involves listening
i like to point out that it actually
contains the word ear the very device
that we use to hear things in the first
place
that's a human ear all right there's
your earlobe
eutragus
your scaphoid fossa parts of the ear
so just remember that here contains the
word ear
here the adverb however let's use this
in an example
the secret treasure should be right here
and in order to keep this one straight i
like to remember that here
rhymes with near
which is what it means right when
something is here it's directly next to
you or near you
so for here with an a there's an ear in
it too but with here with an e it's its
nearness to you
next the words accept and accept these
are pronounced very slightly differently
so accept here is a verb and it means
to go along with or to receive
as in i accept this gift in the name of
spain
and accept on the other hand is a
conjunction and a preposition
which can kind of be used the same way
that but is used
sort of in an everything but way so so
for example i like every vegetable
except zucchini which isn't true i like
zucchini a great deal but you can see
how it's being used like but it's it's
kind of exclusionary
which is how we're going to tell the
difference between these two words this
gives us the basis for our mnemonic so
remember that accept is spelled e x c e
p t which is also the first three
letters of a similar word
exclude so accept exclude stuff
and accept is spelled a-c-c-e-p-t
so we're going to say that's very
similar to
access so accept with an a
bring something in
and accept with an e
keep something out
you can learn anything
david out